Thomas also had the best insight about
2020 that I've yet heard from anybody he
said dad there are two pandemics this
year I said really what what what's the
other one he said well there's there's
obviously covered 19 but there's another
pandemic which is more contagious and
it's called woken 19 and you can catch
woken 19 from the internet so it's more
dangerous than covered 19 I think
there's wisdom amongst the
eight-year-olds Dave that they give me
hope this is the Rubin report and
according to big tech I'm Dave Rubin
reminder everybody to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and click that
notification bell for notifications
that's what the Bell is there for and
joining me today is a historian and
senior fellow at the Hoover Institution
at Stanford University Neil Ferguson
welcome back to the Rubin report it's
great to be back virtually Dave I'd
prefer to be back really but hey it's
the play gear it is the play great year
you know last time you were on the show
you flew in you bolted from the airport
we talked as fast as we could for about
an hour and a half and then you bolted
and left again so this must be very
calming for you to be able to be at home
and relaxed and at a computer because
you're a busy guy it is very calming I
had not spent three months in one
location for 20 years and I think I had
fallen victim to high permeability and
hyper globalization where if I wasn't on
a long-haul flight at least once a week
I felt there was something wrong with my
life and having that all stop has been a
real blessing not everybody gets to work
from home I'm one of the lucky ones who
can and this has also meant more time
with my family so I think we all may
have been suffering from some kind of
collective FOMO as we flew from
conference to conference manically and
covered 19 stopped the world and said
you can all get off now and for some
people it's been difficult for me it's
been literally coming home
but also metaphorically because I'm back
to the kind of life I had when I was a
young academic teaching at Oxford with
little kids and that was my life I read
books I wrote books and I read stories
at night and I'm back to that and it's
great well as most of my audience knows
your wife is the magical amazing I'll
let you add a couple other adjectives
ayaan Hirsi Ali and and you guys do have
a toddler now so you're look at you
enjoying home life you're supposed to be
a stodgy academic and you're enjoying
home life well we have we have two sons
actually I'll add the adjectives shall I
Dave yeah brave beautiful and brilliant
those are the three things that describe
my wife and she's also a wonderful
mother and our two sons one of whom is
eight the others too are a constant
source of of joy to us and and I just
seeing much more of them which is which
is fascinating
I thought homeschooling was an oxymoron
and it turns out actually to work quite
well at least with some kids Thomas
who's eight has been he's really been in
some ways more engaged because he's had
greater freedom to explore and I've been
fascinated to watch him become a little
autodidact and and delve deeply into
into STEM subjects so yeah there is all
sorts of wonderful things that have have
come out of 2020 which is paradoxical
because it's been a horrible year for so
many people
well STEM subjects I thought STEM
subjects were all racist and patriarchal
and part of the oppressive machinery
that is the west or something like that
you're teaching STEM subjects to an
eight year old
well he's teaching them to himself
remember although I'm from a science
background my mother is a physicist and
so as my sister I'm the black sheep of
the family who wandered off into the
dangerous terrain of the humanities and
social sciences but Thomas is a young
man with that clear vision I think he's
identified that humanities and social
sciences are no longer
the places to be and he's been studying
microbiology with considerable zeal and
Tarly at his own initiative Thomas also
had the best insight about 2020 that
I've yet heard from anybody he said dad
there are two pandemics this year I said
really what what what's the other one he
said well there's there's obviously
covered 19 but there's another pandemic
which is more contagious and it's called
woken 19 and you can catch whoa code 19
from the internet so it's more dangerous
than covered 19 I think there's wisdom
amongst the eight-year-olds days that
they give me hope you know most people
make up what their eight-year olds are
saying but I actually believe that
you're an ions offspring said that you
know a lot of a lot of the Twitter
warriors was in there pretending yeah
it's only one of his many insights into
this strange time I I do think his
generations going to surprise people if
he and his friends are anything to go by
there's a kind of healthy skepticism a
sort of South Park quality to this
generation they are very different in
their outlook as far as I can see from a
admittedly small sample from the
generation Z 20-somethings who are
currently in various stages of of
anxiety and and and woken us so I have a
suggestion which I'm sure it's
impossible to to do more than and then
speculate about because we can't poll
eight-year-olds but I think Generation T
the kids who came of age during the
Trump presidency are going to have very
different outlooks partly because I
think they've been slightly false fared
work ideas at school and they do react
like you know Cartman and Kyle and the
kids from South Park which I find quite
encouraging because at 8:00 I was a kind
of instinctive conservative I think most
eight-year-olds are you kind of against
change even when your parents change the
wallpaper in the the living room you're
kind of against it
and I noticed it certain familiar
symptoms and in Thomas I hope it doesn't
all go away when he becomes a teenager
that would be awful well he's gonna have
to go through a phase I hate to tell you
that's that's how it works
well not necessarily because in Britain
we have boarding schools and you just
send away the minute they become
teenagers and they hate teachers instead
of you it's it works remarkably well
that's actually pretty clever all right
so we're gonna do something a little bit
different than I would normally do what
if I was to have you on I want to use
the time with you to sort of celebrate
America and celebrate freedom this is
going to be our July 4th special we're
taping it a little bit before July 4th
but because you have an interesting
immigration story your wife has an
interesting immigration story you are a
historian and and a proud American I
thought you were the right guy to talk
to about this but before we fully get
into that am i correct you've written 14
books is that right I think it might be
15 is it 15 now yeah I think so yeah
that's a lot of books I don't even have
a question to ask I just wanted to say
it because it's an awful lot of books
and as a guy that just wrote one I just
feel like you deserve some credit on
that well the only consolation is I
think that each one is easier than the
one before so the first one is the hard
one and see you know it's not like it's
an art writing books is more like a
building cabinets it's a sort of craft
and once you've done it once the second
one is distinctly easier that's that's
the good news there are people more
prolific than I am and indeed one of my
heroes
the Scottish novelist John Buchan
regarded it as a kind of wasted year if
he hadn't written the book whereas I
think my batting average is a book every
two and a half years or so so I mean I'm
not exceptionally prolific but I did use
to look around at certain universities
where I've worked and marvel at how few
books some of my colleagues were able to
write I don't know what they were doing
the rest of the time I live to write and
reading and writing are the two things
that I I do with the greatest facility
the thinking in the middle is the
difficult bit you do the reading and
then the heart but is the thinking once
you've figured it out the writing is a
relatively straightforward part of the
job all right so between the personal
story the writing and a little bit of
the thinking let's let's talk about
freedom so first I just thought telling
a bit about your own personal
immigration story would be kind of
interesting you you wrote a blog about
it a while back and I think that might
be a nice way to set this whole
conversation up well I've been working
in the United States since around 2002 I
was transatlantic for a while going back
and forward very regularly and it took a
while before I realized that when I was
landing at Boston Logan that felt more
like coming home than landing at
Heathrow there was a kind of gradual
process I decided to come to the United
States partly out of a sense that the
action was here in my field I was
writing a lot of financial history I'd
written a history of the Rothschilds the
English by and large like their
historians to do kings and queens prime
ministers not bankers New York Kanak got
what I was doing more than done London
did and I was kind of toying with the
idea of ever moved to New York
University when 9/11 happens now the
Scots have a propensity to march towards
the sound of gunfire if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell